- On this episode, sports
legend Brandon Steiner stops by.
(rap music)
♫ Hey!
♫ Gary Vee!
♫ You ask questions,
♫ and I answer them.
♫ This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey, everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
and this is episode 261
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
And I gotta tell you, Linda Cohn,
and now, another sports legend.
Brandon, please tell the VaynerNation
who you are and what you do,
and then I'll jump in with something,
and then we're gonna get into it.
- Numbers.
- What's that?
- What do you mean numbers?
- We need numbers.
- You need numbers, for what?
Followers?
- For call-in.
- Oh, for call-in, right, thank you.
Dunc, you're back and sharp.
Guys, start putting in your
phone numbers on Facebook,
so we can call you in a
little bit, but Brandon,
I probably knew that I'm--
- Pretty soon, all your phones
are gonna blow up.
- Well, I know that.
- 'Cuz people got all kinds
of questions and shit
they're gonna wanna ask.
Brandon Steiner, from Steiner Sports.
First of all, love Linda.
You brought the woman goalie.
- [Gary] She's the best.
- The first woman that
I took my sports from,
Linda Cohn, legend, love her.
- Legend.
- Couldn't take my eyes off
that interview, loved it.
- Thank you.
- Um, just love you,
love the show.
- Love you, by the way--
- Love the energy.
- Real quick, I apologize,
I was blown away,
I think I said it, did you
guys air it on your end?
I did Brandon's podcast.
You should definitely
start listening to it.
If you are a sports or an entrepreneur,
you should listen to
it, I said at the end,
that I was blown away
how good you are at it.
Did you guys leave that part in?
(laughs)
When I was like, right,
you did, right?
Guys, I was blown away, obviously
he's been an entrepreneur,
sports memorabilia--
- Well, thank you.
- He'll go into his whole
spiel, but I was like,
I thought you, I don't
know what I thought,
I thought it was gonna like,
a lot of people are just
okay at interviewing,
or what have you, you crushed it.
You're really good at it.
By the way, do you think
we should start a sports,
do you think me, you, and Linda,
well Linda's under contract,
but when Linda's out of her,
I'm starting to think that
I wanna reboot sports radio.
Like you should, do you
want, should we do that?
- Because nobody
interviews anybody anymore,
and that's where the shit is.
These are the people
that are in the grind,
in the whole, they're into it.
That's my whole life.
- Alright, Brandon.
Tell everybody who you are.
- First of all, this guy killed me.
We go to the Ranger game,
the guy does not let me
ask him any questions.
He's interviewing me for three hours.
- You know what's so fuckin', Brandon,
you know what's so crazy about that?
I was literally in a meeting
right now, an hour ago,
knew we were doing this, and was like,
fuck, my energy is not gonna be great,
because there's literally
nothing I need to know
about this guy, 'cuz I fucking drilled him
for over four hours at
a Rangers playoff game.
I was like literally thinking, fuck.
- [Brandon] I thought you were
screwing me at the beginning.
I'm figuring he's gonna
say at the beginning,
but I'm gonna get an
earful, which I'm ready for.
The guy had, I thought he had
the questions written down.
I'm like, he's serious, this
guy, you had done a lot,
you had a handful of
questions every three minutes.
We did watch some of the
game though, that was cool.
But anyway, I've been doing this 30 years.
I love the energy up
here, this reminds me of
what it's like up at Steiner.
A lot of energy, we're looking to kill it.
The guy today wouldn't open up,
wouldn't get the elevator for me today,
I went crazy on the guy
who runs the building.
I'm like, "Dude, you're moving in slow-mo,
"that's not how we roll here."
And that's what I love about this place,
like nobody's in slow-mo here, which,
by the way, if you're out
there and you're in slow-mo,
just click off, we don't need you tonight.
We don't wanna even hear from you, because
at the end of the day, my
day's just getting started,
and I can sense that you're
day's getting started,
and I love that.
- Pff, Brandon, I think,
you know, what I love about business,
because I wasn't able to be
on the field, or the ice,
is it's just like sports.
Speed is a huge variable in
business, just like sports.
If somebody runs a little bit faster,
you know, you get a Deion Sanders,
you get somebody that's a
little bit faster, right?
You know, it really plays out.
- You had the guy from the Food
Network or the Food Channel,
you know, he does the Bar Rescue?
- Yes, yes, from Spike TV.
- I love that show by the way.
- Yes, Jon, yeah.
- So, I was loving that show,
I was tuned in on that show.
I love that, if you haven't,
go back and watch that.
But anyway, you'd said something
that really hit home with me.
You're like, "Find an influencer,
"go to that influencer, send him shit."
And then, tag on, right?
We've been sending shit
from Steiner like everyday
to all these influencers.
They're all freaking posting, it's like,
that was free, by the way,
I appreciate that advice.
- Pleasure, I'm trying to be,
I'm giving free advice everyday and then
people are coming up with excuses.
I'm giving it to you for free
and you still got excuses,
like "I have too many passions."
Pick one, asshole.
- I love sending out the gifts
and then--
- I'm done with that.
By the way, officially, is this 261, Jake?
On episode 261, I'm
putting the gauntlet down,
no more ever, ever using the excuse,
"I have too many passions."
It's just a classic excuse to not do.
"Gary, it really sucks, I'm
really good at so many things,
"and I've so many passions,
that I don't know what to do."
Classic bullshit excuse.
Tell your Phil Rizzuto story.
- You know, it's funny, the
Phil Rizzuto story, I go,
you know, I get a call from
Phil, bounce this check.
I bounce his check, he's
killing me, he's at the track,
that was his spending
money he's giving me.
- By the way, real quick, I
gotta remember my audience,
Phil Rizzuto is like Hall of
Fame legend Yankee player,
and then broadcaster, the
first person I ever heard say,
"Holy cow," 'cuz I grew up in New York.
Like, just a legend guy.
Tough, like old school Yankee.
- In the late '80s,
he's the Yankee because the
Yankees weren't that great
in the late '80s.
- Yeah, they sucked shit then.
- He was the broadcaster.
- Him and Don Mattingly.
- 50-year baseball man.
Calls me up and he's yelling, screaming,
and I'd just started started
Steiner, I was scared as shit.
I didn't know what to do.
So, he goes, "You bounce my checks."
I called Gonzalez at
Citibank up, and I'm like,
"Dude, you bounced Phil Rizzuto's check?
"What is wrong with you?
I'm coming down there."
I come down there, I go, "What
the hell, are you crazy?"
He goes, "Dude, you had two
checks that were gonna bounce."
I said, "Well, why would
you bounce Rizzuto's?"
"The other one was Mickey Mantle."
"Good decision, I appreciate that."
- You guys have heard of that name.
- [Brandon] But, so you know,
I don't wanna bounce Mickey's
check, we need Mickey,
Mickey loved me, and I'm very grateful.
But the thing was, Gary, is that--
- Dunc doesn't know
Mickey Mantle, I knew it,
listen, he's from Sweden, he's nine.
You still don't, you don't know
who Mickey Mantle is, right?
Plus ten, you're 19, from Sweden,
and you do not know who Mickey Mantle is?
- [Brandon] Mickey Mantle,
number seven, the great Mick.
But here's the story on this,
let me finish this story real fast.
- But, before you finish your story,
this man right here is leaving
Vayner, I'm devastated.
- Why, where are you going?
- He wanted to go in-house,
to some big mobile, you know,
I don't wanna blow up his
spot, but, he's a great kid,
he's a Dolphins fan,
which is a huge issue.
I was supposed to see
him, I'm running late,
but I wanna give him a
quick hug and a kiss,
'cuz he's phenomenal
and I'm hoping I'm gonna
get to work with him again.
And I figured if I didn't
say goodbye in person,
there was a chance I
wouldn't work with him again,
so you keep telling your story--
- On a scale of one to 10, was he a?
- He's a, he's a, I think
he's a true nine, guaranteed.
The truth is, I don't even fully know.
It's unfair for me to rank,
my intuition, is he's a nine.
- Wow, that's strong, anyway,
quick thing on Phil Rizzuto,
A nine from Gary is big,
'cuz I don't think he
gives out a lot of nines.
But, the main thing is,
I tell Phil, I said,
"I'm gonna make it up to
you," 'cuz we all screw up.
I'm busting my ass for three years
trying to find work for Phil
Rizzuto everywhere I can.
Finally, the guy who would
never get in the Hall of Fame,
who was always controversial,
"Can Phil get in the Hall of Fame,
"Is he getting in, is he getting in?"
Finally, he gets in the Hall of Fame,
and I got every marketing company
trying to sign Phil Rizzuto,
who doesn't have an agent.
I'm in his living room, and he goes,
"Steiner, guess what? I'm gonna pick you."
"You're kidding me, how, why?"
He goes, "You know when you screwed up,
"you told me you were
gonna make it up to me,
"and every time I turned,
"you were coming up with more work for me,
"doing nice things for
me, and I believe you."
And the moral of that story
is run to your problems.
Most people, when they have a problem,
when they hit a roadblock,
they sprint away.
"Oh, I better stay away from that person."
You have an argument with
your boss, sprint at him.
Go make it up, stay late, do more.
Whatever you can do, do
it, because most people,
they're hiding in the corner,
they got their head down.
Me with Rizzuto, I killed him with work,
killed him with love,
killed him with kindness,
and sure enough the guy
gets in the Hall of Fame,
and to get a Yankee Hall of Fame,
I had two employees at the time,
two, it was a game changer.
Run to your problems,
don't run away from them.
- You know what's interesting about that?
You know, I was looking at Tyler,
I gave him that advice six
months ago on something that,
I think we will always think
about and it worked for him.
And even more interesting to
me is the reverse of that.
Brandon's story is so interesting to me.
You could crush it for
somebody for six years,
then have a problem,
and a lot of people get
so bent out of shape,
"I was fucking delivering
for this guy for six years,
"and now I dropped the ball
"and he doesn't wanna know
my name or list anything."
You're only as good as your last at bat.
- [Brandon] You know, or you
better come back twice as hard
if you do drop the ball, you know?
- Right?
You gotta run at your problems early,
but you also have to have the humility
that the market is the
market is the market.
The game passes everybody by.
Even this piece of shit Tom Brady who
who the hell knows why
he's still so goddamn good,
eventually, Jesus fucking
Christ, eventually,
the game's gonna pass him by.
Let's get into the first phone call,
we're gonna get more into
your backstory Brandon, 'cuz
you really are an incredible
(phone rings)
East Coast entrepreneur,
which I am as well,
and I wanna get more to that story,
but let's first get this first question.
- Good morning, Andrew.
- This is Andrew.
- Andrew, it's Gary Vee, and you're on
The #AskGaryVee show with Brandon Steiner.
- [Andrew] Oh my gosh,
man, that is insane.
What's going on man?
- The life is good.
What's your question?
- [Andrew] Yeah, man, so I was wondering,
so I'm kind of in this spot where,
you know, I'm 27.
I've been entrepreneurial my whole life.
My grandma used to buy me
five-pound bags of gummy bears
in pre, not pre-school, but
you know, elementary school.
I'd put 'em in Ziploc bags and flip 'em.
So, I've been kind of doing
that thing my whole life,
and, man, I'm at this
crossroads right now, man,
of really trying to figure out
what direction I wanna take
my next step, I've tried
a few things, I guess,
my question to you is,
were there ever defining
moments where you just knew
what the next step needed to be?
If you were debating
something, and you just said,
"You know what, this is it?"
- What are you, what are you,
what are you doing right now?
- [Andrew] So, right now, I'm
currently working for Verizon.
Just sales rep there.
Got laid off from the oil industry,
and actually I'm doing videography
as my passion thing now
that I'd like to monetize and I actually
made a Jets hype video for
you clearly didn't watch--
- I know, you sent it to me, yep, I know.
- [Andrew] Yeah, I actually sent it to you
like 30 minutes ago at the end of--
- I love it, I love it.
I love the other day you caught
me perfectly, you're like,
"Hey," like you knew exactly,
I don't remember exactly what it was,
but you're like, "Hey, there
is no sports right now,
"so watch the,"
(laughs)
There was something that
you did that was clever,
and it was really funny.
I decided I'm still not gonna
watch it 'cuz I wanted to
virtually stick it to
you without knowing you,
but I did like that effort.
- It's all good, man.
- So, Brandon, you know, it's funny,
because I asked you so many questions,
you had some pretty
interesting twists and turns,
you were in the hospitality
business early in your career,
then you saw things, like,
you had some really interesting moments
when you decided to rep
talent and everything.
Have the moments when you
made the right decisions,
whether repping Phil,
later with the restaurants,
I know we have to catch
everybody up on these things,
did you just know?
- No.
No, I knew I was gonna, at the endgame.
Like a kid asked me today,
he was up in the offices,
"Did you ever think you were
gonna be this successful?"
And I said, "Fuck, of course.
"Do you think I started
this thing to be a failure?
"Yeah, I started this
thing to be successful."
- Can I ask you a really
important question?
- [Brandon] Sure.
- Will you end up being
less or more successful
that you thought when you were 17?
- That's a great question.
I hope that I will be more
successful than I thought,
and right now--
- Whatchu got to hate?
- And right now, I'm less
successful than I thought, I am.
And I'm not happy about it,
I gotta be honest with you.
- [Gary] I love your face.
I feel like that's gonna
happen with me, too.
- I'm not giving in yet.
I still got something to do about it
and I still got something to say about it
and I'm not giving in,
and paint's not dry.
But one thing I would tell
this gentleman on the phone is that
target, target, target.
I think that you don't dream enough.
When you got the opportunity,
you got a blessing here
even though it sounds like
a little bit of adversity.
I love the idea of taking a step back,
taking out a white piece
of paper, that's blank,
and write down 10 of your dream companies,
and target the shit out of 'em.
Find out everything you
can about those companies.
- Or open the Notes app and write it down.
- [Brandon] Yeah, problem
with Notes, sorry about the--
- I'm kidding, I'm kidding,
I'm kidding, I'm having fun.
- I love to go find 10 companies,
by the way, I still do this to this day,
like, why should I work with a company
that I really don't wanna work with?
Why wouldn't I work
with my dream companies
I always wanted to work with?
This being one of 'em even, over here.
But at the end, Google
search those 10 companies,
so you know everything about 'em,
every time something
gets written about 'em,
you get that email online,
and then start looking at decision makers,
and then figure how you're
gonna get your foot in the door,
whether it be the mail room,
the lunchroom, whatever.
Once you get your foot in the door,
you're working for a dream
company, a dream opportunity,
your energy and passion will be there,
and then you find your way.
I always work with and for the people
that I always dreamt of.
I always thought I was gonna
work with Mickey Mantle,
I figured it out, wasn't easy.
I always thought, you know,
"Wow, imagine if I can get Derek Jeter."
Figured it out.
Yankees.
- In a big way.
- Do you know how hard it is to partner up
with the Yankee name next to your name?
You have Yankee/Steiner.
Not easy, two and a half years.
Did it.
That was a huge coup.
Andrew, I think, look, man,
I'll be honest with you, like,
I think you should spend time on debating
what creates insecurity or questionings
or things of that nature,
because that will help you way more than
the micro-decision on
what's the next move, right?
- Yeah.
- Like for me, for me
it's never been about anything other than
I just know it's gonna work itself out,
I believe in my skills,
I put myself in a position to succeed,
and I don't question things,
and I think a lot of, the
reason I push patience is,
it's a big thing, like,
optimism, patience, even
Brandon's answer, he's like,
"The paint's not dry."
How old are you?
- 58.
- Right?
- I'm 27.
Oh, pff.
- No worries.
Andrew, Brandon's 58-years-old.
All these 20- and 30-year-olds
that watch me all the time,
and obviously because of
Instagram and YouTube,
if they knew, and I say
this all the time, at 41,
I love looking at Brandon, because at 58,
I know he's just as on fire as I am at 41,
as you are Andrew at 27.
And I've got some good news for you,
95% of 27-year-olds don't
believe that to be true.
Andrew, 95% of the
people, 97% of the people
believe that Brandon and I
are old, when they're 27.
That's just the way it is.
And that's the part that fucks them up.
Because if you knew,
if you knew that double
your age plus four, right?
You get to be Brandon, and he's still
just as on fire right now as you are.
All of a sudden, you're not crippled
about the next six months.
- Yeah.
- By the way, I give you,
I give you permission, I'm
giving you officially permission
to be successful and to
go after all the dreams
and all the things that you wanna do,
without any roadblockages.
Use my card, use my
name, any way you want.
- [Andrew] Awesome, well I
sincerely appreciate that,
and it's cool of you, too, because I mean,
my father-in-law is a very
successful entrepreneur,
and he's in his 50s,
and he's still opening up
businesses left and right,
and he's just excited every day about it.
So, it's cool to get
to see that firsthand.
- Andrew, I think if that's the case,
if you've got the luxury
of that, then really,
I'll throw another curve ball at you,
or give you another thing to ponder,
you gotta try shit.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- Like, with,
making the trying the ROI, right?
- [Andrew] For sure.
- The thing that I think
has always worked for me is
I make them win-win
situations from the get.
That I've decided that
even the doing was the win,
thus I'm almost numb to the outcome.
Like from experience, or this and that,
back to something that
you and I crossover on.
My first baseball card show,
I wanted to pay $20 for the table.
The whole way to the Phillipsburg Mall,
me and my partners at the time,
my partners in sixth, seventh
grade, we're gonna pay $20.
We get there,
some monster guy, that
looks like King Kong Bundy,
comes out, right?
Some big fuckin' 400-pound dude comes out,
and he goes, "What?"
And we're like, "We want
a table, you got any?"
And he's like, "Yeah, we got one more."
Who knows if that's true?
(laughs)
We go, "How much?"
- It's always the last one.
- He goes, "$120."
I go, "We'll take it."
(laughs)
And then we, that was,
he's like, "Well, bring
the money tomorrow,"
and we just like start
walking out of the mall,
and my friends are in a coma.
You know, like $120 is like a billion.
And I'm like cool, but then
I start being like, "Fuck."
And then I start getting nervous,
and I'm like, "What am I gonna do?"
And like, I've got it, but
that seems like a whole lot.
- It was a lot.
- And my dad,
who I never talked to back
then, to his credit, he says,
"You know, it's gonna be
worth the experience."
And honestly, maybe from that day on,
that has been a credo of mine.
Everything I do, the
second I decided to do it,
I had already won.
And whether it worked
or not, the learnings,
or the upside of the execution,
were gonna be KPI, ROI,
the thing I was working towards.
- Sometimes you get caught
up in how much you're paying,
not about how much you can make.
I always used to get caught
up with how much we're paying,
but then how much can
we make on this thing?
If you focus that much about
how much you could make on it
as much as how much you're paying,
sometimes you don't have
to spend as much time
on how much you're paying,
you pay it, because,
you can make a ton of
money on the damn thing.
And I've learned that the hard
way with a bunch of players.
I had David Wells for his perfect game,
missed him by $2, didn't
talk to him for five years.
Thought the guy was gonna run
over me in the parking lot.
But,
I have regained relationship with him now.
But I learned from that,
and that was a big not-get.
I almost went out of business
because we didn't have him.
Because I had these perfect game pieces,
I needed him to put him on it.
But, at the end you learn,
it's like, wait a minute,
I was so caught up in the two bucks, 'cuz,
- [Gary] What is it two, oh, per sign.
- Yeah, he wanted 35, I offered him 32.
I'm like, shoulda just
given him the goddamn money,
but I didn't wanna do it.
Meanwhile, I coulda made
a ton of money on it,
I wasn't focused on how much I could make,
I was focused on how
much I was gonna pay him.
- [Gary] Of course.
- Stupid.
- Andrew, thank you, brother.
I hope you get some value outta this.
- Well, I appreciate it, man.
- Take care.
- Good luck.
- [Gary] Alright, as we go
to the next question, so,
as a kid, what were you about?
- Hustle.
- Always.
- Yeah, hustle.
I didn't wanna waste a second.
- Where'd you grow up?
- Grew up in Brooklyn, Kings
Highway, Ocean Parkway.
I played sports.
I remember going to my mother and saying,
"I need a career change, I
need something to change,
"I don't have time to
play with my friends."
You know, she's like,
"You're 12, what are you
talking about career change?"
I said, "I gotta go."
That's when I went and
got the paper route,
and I started delivering,
the papers were cool,
other people were doing it,
but I was delivering
milk, bagels, everything.
Fuck, and I had two shopping
carts, I was rocking.
- [Gary] You were like
the UberEATS of the '60s?
- I was rocking.
The old ladies, man, were
like, "How cute is this boy?
"He's so nice."
I had to go two shopping
carts in the morning,
before I was at school.
- You're like, I'm super nice,
two-for-one bagels, darling.
- But after school,
but after school, I was rolling.
Hey, I bought so many bagels,
the bagel guy hired me
and taught me how to bake bagels.
And bagels got hot with bagel
nosh and everything else.
I could bake, now I know this,
my daughter's gonna kill me--
- [Gary] Do you make a mean bagel?
- But I invented the everything bagel.
I just wanna clarify that right now.
- [Gary] What did he just say?
- I invented the everything bagel.
- Hold on.
This whole fucking episode has just been--
- I just wanna fucking
clear that up, right now.
I invented the everything bagel,
not Seth Godin who has claimed that.
- [Gary] Wait a minute Seth
Godin claims that, too?
- Seth Godin claimed that, but
that was 10 years after me.
I definitely did that.
- Wait a minute.
This is true, now first
of all, does somebody,
I'm gonna text Seth Godin.
I'm gonna bring you back and Seth,
and we're gonna debate who invented,
so, wait a minute, both of
you characters are claiming--
- He has claimed that, I've read that,
but I've definitely went out with that--
- Understood, let's not
worry about him for a minute.
You, Brandon.
- Yeah, I'll tell ya how.
- No, no, don't tell me anything yet.
You...
- Invented the everything
bagel, no questions.
- Jesus, this is huge,
I'm excited about this,
because this is what's
called a win-win situation.
Either, I know the guy that
invented the everything bagel,
or we're gonna get you.
- Oh, no, you're not--
- I, no--
- No, no, I invented the everything bagel,
and what's crazy is my kids,
out of everything I've done,
when friends come over, he goes,
"This is my dad, he invented
the everything bagel."
And I'm like, "I think I've
done a few other things
"since then, but like"--
- Brandon, Brandon.
You are an all-time entrepreneur,
an all-time sports entrepreneur,
and all-time East Coast my
kinda style entrepreneur.
If you did indeed invent
the everything bagel,
when you die, they're gonna
say, "Brandon Steiner,
"the guy who invented the
everything bagel, has died today."
- Is anything better
than an everything bagel?
- No.
- I'm sitting there--
- Okay, listen, you're done.
We know that you don't
know American culture.
- Do you understand, Gary, that,
when I take that job, the guy says,
he was The Bagel Factory
on East 4th Street
and Kings Highway, he starts
baking at four in the morning,
he says, "Would you mind
coming to bake with me
"at four in the morning?
"You could then deliver
your papers afterwards."
I said, "Sure, I can do that."
I go home, my mother says,
"That may be a little early,
"ya gotta go to school,
deliver the papers."
I said, "I got it."
Of course, I fell asleep
in the middle of school,
and this and that, so I
quit the paper route job,
get this job, the night baker quits,
I get this job for $1.75 an hour, huge.
I'm feeling rich.
- That's a lot of money.
- But, there's nobody coming
in the store at night,
I was bored outta my mind.
- What year was this?
- '73, '72?
- It's a lot of money.
I always had my money
stacked up on my dresser,
so I'm bored outta my mind.
- You were one of those guys
who puts pictures on Instagram,
and shows their cash?
- No.
- You were the original
douche bag Instagram guy?
- No.
- Okay, just wanna make sure.
- But the mistake was putting
that cash on my dresser
'cuz my brother always
stole all the money.
Anyway, I don't even care about that.
- Brandon, real quick.
Who's next on the call?
- By the way,
at night is when I invented
the everything bagel,
because there was nobody
coming in the store.
So I figured let me throw
all these different seeds
on to see what it's like.
- Brandon, Brandon.
- Alright.
- No, no, no.
I'm asking you a real question.
Obviously you made an
everything bagel back then.
Do you believe--
- No, I invented it.
No, I was the first person
I've ever seen that from.
But you gotta remember
this factory in '73,
there wasn't a lot bagel stores.
This is a route that delivered bagels
everywhere and everywhere,
and Bagel Nazis hadn't started yet.
This is early,
I'm 12-years-old, there wasn't
a lot going on bagel-wise.
- [Gary] Let's get to the next call.
$0.05 for a bagel, by the way,
wowzer, $0.05 for a bagel.
Five.
And a coffee was nothing.
(phone ringing)
- Quarter, less?
- Nothing, but you know,
coffee's not like it is now anyway.
- No, I know, how much was it?
- I never drank a cup
of coffee, I don't know.
- [Gary] But you know
how much it was sold for.
- Probably a couple pennies.
- [Coady] Hello.
- Slice of pizza was $0.15.
- Who do we have?
Coady, it's Gary Vee,
you're on The #AskGaryVee
Show with Brandon Steiner.
- Made a lot of progress, here.
- [Coady] This is unreal.
No, I'm very excited,
I listen to you every single morning.
- I appreciate that, my man.
- On the way to walk,
the walk to work, man.
- Thank you brother, what's your question?
- [Coady] So I'm just starting
out a little business here,
I'm basically just selling online clothes.
- Okay.
- [Coady] And I'm doing
videos, all the proceeds
go toward random acts of kindness.
- Okay, I love that.
- [Coady] So, basically,
what I wanna know is,
how do I find and afford a DRock?
In the very beginning stages.
- Got it, so you're selling t-shirts,
and all the profits then go
into random acts of kindness,
and you wanna document that journey?
- [Coady] Absolutely,
every step of the way.
- Great, and what's
your Instagram account?
- [Coady] Right now,
it's @-R-T-H-L-shop, dot,
no, sorry, @rthlshop.
- R
- T, yep.
- T.
H.
- H.
- L.
- L, shop.
- [Coady] Shop.
- Great, and where are you based?
- [Coady] You probably
never even heard of it.
Newfoundland, Canada.
- I've heard of it, of
course, I'm a hockey fan.
Okay, good news.
(laughs)
Somebody, here's, you
have an advantage in being
in fucking bumble-fuck Canada.
Ready for it?
Here it comes.
- Yep.
- Two kids are gonna DM you right now,
and are gonna do it for
free, it's a done deal.
Brandon is such a draw, there's
plenty of people watching.
There's two to three people
right now, who are literally,
and maybe it's a month from
now, maybe it's a week from now,
I guarantee two or three are gonna DM you,
and be willing to do it,
to build their résumé.
14-year-old Brandon and
Gary are DMing you right now
and saying, "Bro, I'll do it for free."
'Cuz they wanna put something on tape.
- I love it.
I wanna tell ya something.
- Unreal.
- You know, that every--
- That's what the--
- I love that you do that act of kindness,
you know, every morning at
Steiner, my assistant's here,
Jake, he's uh, we do two
acts of kindness every day.
- Why not three?
- We send two every day.
- We do zero, but don't you do three?
- We sometimes do, but we always do two.
- I love it.
- We always do two.
Every day before anything else--
- Hold on, hold on, our call is here,
Brandon, Brandon, there's a caller here.
- Go ahead, sorry.
- Go ahead.
- [Brandon] Go ahead.
- [Coady] Yeah, so, my very first video,
I just went into a coffee
shop, I set up a camera,
I anonymously just paid
for people's coffee,
and almost every single person
wanted to pay it forward.
And then my friend who was working
messaged me two days later, and she said
someone that I bought coffee for
bought a large coffee
for himself, and then
five large coffees for the
next five people that came in,
which I thought was pretty cool how
people just wanted to pay it forward.
- Dude, doing the right
thing is always the way.
- Dude, I'm contacting
you tomorrow morning.
I'm buying some t-shirts, you're
first on my list tomorrow.
I'm just telling you right now,
you're first on my list tomorrow.
- Awesome.
- Coady, Coady do me a favor.
Dude, Coady, hold on, hold on.
- Yes.
- As soon as you get
the order from Brandon,
you need to email Gary at VaynerMedia,
and I'm gonna buy one more
t-shirt than Brandon does.
- Don't fuck with me.
I may be buying a lot, you Facebook me,
Facebook me tonight, right
now, so I have all the details
so I can give, I'll get
this shit going tonight.
And Gary better have, you
better have, you're gonna have--
- Absolutely will.
- But, Brandon,
I've already trumped you.
Doesn't matter what you're gonna do,
I'm gonna buy one more t-shirt than you,
and so I don't know why you
sent him to fuckin' Facbeook,
but it doesn't matter because--
- Well I said it, because it's the,
I go there every night before I go to bed,
I go to Facebook, I check
my messages out, that's why.
- Coady, listen, you
sold a bunch of t-shirts,
you got a free videographers
coming your way,
life is good today.
- You better fuckin' win.
- I'm on your, I'm on you.
- [Coady] Maybe when you buy the Jets,
we'll get the symbol on the jersey, eh?
- I mean, listen, let's
not got carried away.
I mean, I'm thrilled, but that's
gonna cost a lot of money.
- [Brandon] He's dreaming,
he's dreaming with you.
- I appreciate it, my man.
Good dude, alright,
let's get another call.
Brandon, do you, you know
it's funny, I got to know you,
I'm getting to know you more and more,
you know what I like about you
and what I really like about
entrepreneurship a little bit?
That I'm hoping it
continues to build momentum,
which is why I'm bringing it up right now,
I like that people love it so much
they wanna give back to the game.
One thing I've always noticed from you,
is you always wanna
put on the young, like,
we see ourselves, right?
It's cool.
- I love it.
- [Gary] I love it, too, and
you're really good at it.
- And I love what I see in the kids.
I love when I see it in the kids, too.
- Of course, the game.
- I just can't, just,
just can't get enough of it.
- We're ready to go, Matthew?
Right?
Like I've noticed that in you.
(phone rings)
Like you love that part of it, right?
- I love the teaching, I love speaking.
- 'Cuz it's sports, right?
- Love it, I love it, love the
young entrepreneurship kind.
- Matthew, it's Gary Vee,
you're on The #AskGaryVee Show
with Brandon Steiner.
- [Matthew] Gary and Brandon,
I cannot believe it, man.
- Believe it, brother.
- I'm sitting here,
I've hit several different
spots, just waiting online, man,
it's great to finally talk to you guys.
- No worries, where are you from?
- [Matthew] Austin, Texas.
- Love it, what's your question?
- [Matthew] You know,
I've been grinding through
the same industry for
about 15 years, I love it,
I'm passionate about it, it is
not a sexy profession at all,
but it is something that
brings home the bacon, man,
it feed my family, it feeds me,
and other passions that I have,
but it's a, it's not a nine
to five, it's a sales job,
I'm in it all the time.
So I'm pursuing other
passions, other wants,
other ideas that I have, but again,
I've listened to you talk about,
"Hey, you need six hours of sleep,
"and you need a grind on your
second job, your extra job."
But, man alive, there's
only so much I can do
within a shortened period of time.
- I get it.
So.
- And I've gotta provide.
I've gotta provide for my family.
- You're not wrong, so,
now let's get to the most
interesting part, and...
- [Matthew] And I'll continue to grind.
I'll continue to do
what I can, when I can,
as often as I can, and--
- And I think that's the
punchline, brother, right?
Like, life's about alternatives,
like I think that's awesome
that you're dealing with the practicality,
and look, by the way, when I
talk about six hours of sleep,
you know, some people need
seven, some people need eight.
And that's fine, to me,
as long as you feel good
about what you're doing when
you're on the field, right?
As long as you good about
your 14, 16, 17 hours, and,
don't forget you've gotta fix the plane
while you're flying it.
Like, if you wanna get outta
the situation that you're in,
your only option, you
only have one option,
it is to grind in those four,
five, six hours that you have,
and it will take longer because
you don't have 18 hours to
just put it into this thing.
The problem is, you have no alternative.
It sounds like you have
responsibilities that you've
made in your own head,
financial responsibilities,
emotional responsibilities,
and you have to deliver on that, right?
- [Matthew] Every day.
- So I think what people
have to understand is
so does everybody, in shape or
form, have a version of that.
And you just gotta navigate
it the best you can,
and not be crippled by it,
and try to be as successful
as you can on those off-hours
to hopefully create that
world where it switches over,
where you can do that full-time.
Brandon?
- I also think you just
gotta give yourself
at least 30 minutes a day,
just to think about the
possibilities and what-if,
and do a little daydreaming.
Usually, I do it while I'm exercising,
but it's really important
to give yourself time
to just think about what-if and daydream.
I'm a master-daydreamer.
I like daydreaming when I'm walking
and just thinking about what-if, because
if you don't give yourself that time,
it's difficult.
You gotta picture it, for
me, I like to picture, like,
wow, I'm gonna get, I'm gonna go and see,
like I have this whole thing,
I'm gonna do this whole thing with Obama,
I wanna do his first autograph signing.
It's like my dream, I've
already, I've pictured it,
what I'm gonna say to him, and
I'm just working backwards.
Sometimes you picture
something, just work backwards,
but give yourself the 30 minutes,
a few times a week at least, to do that.
- I like that.
- Yeah.
- [Matthew] I appreciate that,
and I'm giving myself that time, I mean,
I learned it from you, Gary,
is give myself that
time between, you know,
I've got three little kids
ranging from 8- to 2-years-old,
and they're, you know,
them and my wife are
my number one clients.
They come first, above
everything else, but it's,
I'm passionate about the job that I have,
I love helping other
people achieve their goals,
that's always been my number one goal,
and it's trying to, at,
you know, your age, Gary,
I mean, I'm 42-years-old, I
gotcha by a couple months.
I'm trying to take that time
to briefly become introverted
enough to follow my dream,
my passion when I have time on,
somebody else may consider
it like off-time, man,
but I just keep grinding,
but I can't give up,
and I don't wanna give up.
- You shouldn't.
- The passions that I have
for the business that I'm in right now.
- And listen my man, if
you're good, then you're good.
The reason I try to get
everybody to be selfish,
is the best way to be
selfless, is you're happy.
And everybody's trying to like,
if you're making everybody else
happy and you're miserable,
you're gonna crack and you're gonna regret
and then you're not
doing anybody any favors
if you crack at 49, and blame
everybody for your shit.
Everybody makes their bed, sleep in it.
You will never hear me complain
about not having enough
time with my kids or family,
because I'm making choices.
I have friends who,
all they do is complain
about not being with their family,
that have $100,000,000 in the bank.
I'm like, if you complain about that,
then spend more time with the family.
Then in reverse,
all you have is people that
complain about not having more,
and they wanna, but
it's because they go to
every single softball game and recital,
you make your bed.
And if you're happy,
man, then you're good.
- Yeah, no question, so you're
in a great town, by the way,
Austin.
- What's that, my friend?
- [Matthew] I'm sorry, Brandon, go ahead.
- I was just gonna say, Austin's
got so many opportunities,
so much growth, it's so vibrant,
you're in a really special town.
I mean, Austin is just off
the hook as far as energy,
the vibrance, the youth, I mean,
there's a lot of opportunity.
You may need to kinda reset a little bit
and rethink about some
of the opportunities that
may have passed you, said no to you,
and go back and ask again.
Things have changed a lot in Austin,
you may wanna go back
to some of those things.
- I wanna go back to that.
Were you saying that
you're content, but hungry?
Is that where you were going?
- [Matthew] I'm content with what I have.
I've been in the mortgage
industry for 15 years,
again, it's not sexy.
I love the company I work
with, Axia Home Loans,
but it's not,
it's not everything that I
know that I have a passion for,
it's not every last thing that I know
I've got rattling around in head.
It's hard for me to narrow
the field of saying,
"Okay, I've got so many thoughts,
"so many ideas of what I can do."
Not necessarily just in this industry,
but in other things as well.
I love what I'm doing,
but I know that I have more
potential, I know that there's
something else that I wanna do.
- Matthew, Matthew, Matthew.
- [Matthew] Sir, Yessir.
- You're not fully content.
- And nor should you be.
- And, by the way, there's
nothing wrong with that, and, or,
And/or I'm gonna throw you
a completely different curve ball.
I would argue that I'm content,
which would throw
everybody for a curve ball,
but I am.
Like, in a lot of ways, I
feel like I'm super content,
like, I'm content because I
get to play my game, right?
Like it's not that I need more,
it's not that I need to
buy the Jets tomorrow,
or be on more covers, or have
another great investment,
or 400,000,000 for Vayner.
My content part, I
actually think I'm content.
I actually would argue,
Brandon, you're content,
because you're playing your game, right?
And so Matthew, the thing that
I want people to understand
is content versus "I'm okay"
and/or "I'm solid, but",
you know, I feel like
I'm content yet hungry,
because I'm doing exactly
what I wanna be doing.
If you listen carefully to
the way you described it,
I wouldn't call that being content.
And, it's okay to, go ahead.
- [Matthew] Let me throw this out,
you were or were not content
with just VaynerMedia,
before you went off to VaynerSports,
and getting into music,
there was something else that
drove you that direction,
some other want.
It wasn't that you
didn't love VaynerMedia,
it was, "Is that it?"
Or do you see other opportunities
in doing something else?
- Yeah, I think the key
is don't be satisfied.
- [Gary] Yeah, that's a different thing.
- You know, be content,
but don't be satisfied.
God, I love Steiner
Sports, I mean my company,
God, it's like my child,
but I'm not satisfied.
- And you can get into
semantics with these words,
here's what I would say for
everybody who's watching,
I'm just desperate for
everybody to get in that zone,
like, look, anybody who
watches my show or calls me
is already different than me,
because I'm not doing that
with anybody ever, ever.
And so for me,
I'm always trying to
think about that insight.
What is it, why have I gone to a place
where I don't even talk to Steve Ross,
or anybody who's done it?
I'm just so in my own insular place.
What is it that I have there, what is it?
Is it, by the way, it might
not even be a strength,
is it a weakness?
Is it do we all learn differently?
I don't think it's some superpower,
I'm always just trying to say, what is it?
And it's what makes me know
that I'm in a different place
than a lot of people
that consume my content,
doesn't make me better,
makes me different.
And I'm trying to find
angles to throw at you guys
to bring you value, make sense?
- [Matthew] Love it.
- Love it, love it.
- Cool, my man, alright.
You know, we're gonna sneak one more in,
I know Tyler, you're gonna freak
out, but I can't leave yet,
'cuz I'm having too much, with,
Brandon, how old is this book?
- Um, I think that's
about three years old now,
two and a half years old.
- Let's make sure we
link up Brandon's book,
let's get his Amazon rank up,
he'll be happy about that.
- You can pick it up on SteinerSports.com.
- Oh, he wants higher.
Did you notice what Brandon did there?
Very sneaky thing.
- No, no, I love Amazon.
Don't, don't, take that
back, I do love Amazon.
- You're disrespecting the network effect,
if your rank grows, you
may actually sell more,
and actually then make more of a net,
you're worried about--
- Eh, go to Amazon.
- Aha, it's a David
Wells 2.0 moment, there.
- Yeah, you're probably right.
You know, I love Amazon,
they've been very supportive,
other than that, go to
Steiner Sports, you know,
it's just, yeah, but you
know something though?
- Brandon, I think--
- The business is--
- It's a tough business, what?
- Chris.
Brandon, I think I'm gonna
have to do a signing with you.
I'm gonna have to be the first
entrepreneur to do a thing.
- [Brandon] There's no question.
- I think we just came up with a big idea.
- There's no question, there's no doubt.
- [Chris] This is Chris.
- Chris, this is Gary Vee.
- 'Sup, Chris?
- And you're on The #AskGaryVee
Show with Brandon Steiner.
- [Chris] How you guys doing, man?
- Super well.
- [Chris] Dude, I can't
believe I'm talking to you,
I'm sitting there just reposting
and reposting, trying to
get a hold of ya, I'm a big
fan of both of you guys.
Thanks so much for--
- Well, you made it,
where are you from?
- Putting me on the show.
The number one town, the
United States of America.
- New York City?
- Charleston, South Carolina.
- Oh, sorry, got it okay,
Charleston, South Carolina.
What's your question?
- [Chris] So, I'm a sports psychologist,
I also dabble in politics as well.
I was a sports psychologist
out of college,
I went to Cal State Fullerton
where they have the number one degree,
master's degree and undergraduate
degrees in the country
in sports psychology.
I, then, was a coach in track
and field in Connecticut
for about seven years, I
had about 50 All-Americans.
Then New Haven became the 14th
most violent city in America.
- Yes.
- So, I left.
I left coaching, got involved
in community activism,
starting out as a volunteer,
starting out after
volunteer making $5 an hour,
to where, in four years,
I was running four
states for Bernie Sanders
in this last political
campaign as a state director,
when he ran for president.
- Understood.
- [Chris] And then, I
decided to get back into
sports psychology and mental
conditioning, and do that
for sports teams kinda
peppered across the country.
But I'm really looking
to try to find out a way
to expand my business,
because right now
everything is word of mouth
amongst the people that I've worked with.
And I'm trying to really get
the Instagram thing going,
the Twitter thing.
- Do you, do you have,
do you have money to spend on marketing?
Or are you gonna have to
go grassroots and organic?
- [Chris] Probably gonna have to go
grassroots and organic.
- Well, then you're in the
word of mouth business,
and what you need to do is
create content organically
on the social networks that is shareable.
So, I would put out your best information
for free on the Internet,
because that is the number one
insight to how to get people
to share your content.
- [Chris] Cool, that's what
I'm doing, I'm creating a blog,
like I have an article that
goes out about once a week,
I'm trying to work Instagram really hard,
I put out a couple of things
there, I started Anchor,
I've done podcasts with people.
- Are you doing this full-time?
- [Chris] Yes, because I still
work with political campaigns
and that's the thing that
really keeps everything running.
And I'm also working on, you know,
pretty much nonprofit and political stuff
is the thing that keeps
my money coming in,
but really sports psych is
where I wanna end up doing
more of my time than the politics.
- Look, so many people are
gonna be having this model,
I'm gonna say it one last time,
fixing the plane while you're flying it.
One blog post on your blog
is probably not gonna be enough volume
to get to where you need to get to.
You know, three times a week
on Facebook in full long form,
so people can share it, is
gonna give you a better chance
than one post on your blog
that nobody's going to.
So, I think these are the subtle things
of how I'm thinking about
it, do you see what I mean?
- One quick thing also,
what's the biggest
sports team in your area?
- [Chris] Well, we're in Charleston,
there ain't no big sports teams around,
so I work for all--
- College, college.
The College of Charleston,
who I do work with,
I work with their baseball organization.
- Alright, well why not
work with all their teams?
And that's a more popular post,
you've got the kids there
to kind of help you as well
to do those posts.
Why not get more engaged at the school?
Work with all those coaches and teams,
and use that as a stepping stone
to help you get with other
teams outside of Charleston.
- I mean, look, we can sit
here for the rest of our lives
and spitball ideas,
how long have you been
putting out the content
on Instagram and your blog?
Tell the truth, 'cuz
we're gonna double check,
and if you lie we're gonna kill ya.
- [Chris] Really
aggressively for about, well,
I actually have your advice, Gary,
and I had an intern for the fall of 2016,
and I kinda dropped off in the spring,
but this summer, I'm posting
like almost every day
very aggressively and, um,
you know, it is helping.
I am getting people DMing me from that,
and saying I'm seeing your content.
One day I had 50 new followers
'cuz I put up something
that was pretty good.
So, I'm just trying to figure out a way,
I think Instagram is
really being a big help,
because as soon as people
message me through them--
- How-how-how, how old are you?
- [Chris] I'm 35.
- Love it.
As long as you're pumped
about this breaking out at 41,
and you do exactly what you're doing
for the next six years in a row,
you're probably gonna break out.
- It's true, it takes time.
- That's the plan, man.
- That's it man, listen,
the tactics matter.
Watch what I'm doing.
I didn't post that life
and legacy post on Facebook
in its really long form the other day
for kicks and giggles.
I'm a big believer that Facebook is
the number one place
people should be blogging.
- [Chris] Okay, cool,
cool, that helps out a lot.
- You got it, alright man, good luck.
- I'll tell you a quick story.
I started blogging, you know
I'm half illiterate, you know,
I'm like, I can barely read, right?
- [Gary] Yep, I can't read for shit.
- So, I couldn't get
100 people on my blog.
- Right.
- I went and sent an email,
I said, "If you don't
register my blog today,"
'cuz I've got about 100 employees,
I said, "I'm gonna fire you."
I got 100, that's how I got my first 100.
And instead, I went around and said,
"Listen, I appreciate that,
I wasn't gonna fire you,
"but could you please
just tell one friend?"
Then I got to 200.
Now we have a little over 100,000.
- Is it in your signature, of your email?
I believe the signature of your email
is one of the great hacks of all time.
You're constantly interacting on email.
The signature of your email
is like a 1999-2004 hack,
that still is so outrageously relevant.
- [Brandon] You still like the signature?
- 100%, 'cuz if you're a businessperson
that's emailing all the time,
it's fucking unbelievable.
It's in there and it's
no different than, uh,
I mean, I update URL in
my LinkedIn all the time,
I mean, excuse me, in my Instagram,
because I know a lot of
people are clicking that.
And every quarter, once a year,
I change my signature for,
you know, I have a sneaker coming out,
I'm sure I'll link to that.
Or if I have a book coming,
Crushing It, the followup to
Crush It, comes out in January.
That will go into the signature.
- You're gonna have an autograph line.
- You know, exactly.
- We gotta do autograph line.
- We gotta do something.
- A bat.
I'm thinking it's a bat.
- Brandon, Brandon.
Let's do this.
- It's a bat.
- Let's start talking behind the scenes,
let's come up with the
first signature concept
for an entrepreneur with Steiner Sports.
- [Brandon] I think it's a bat.
- Well, look, it needs to be authentic.
- [Brandon] Who wouldn't
want a Crushing It bat?
- No, hold on, hold on, don't
force anything on me, okay?
Let's have a creative--
- I was suggesting.
- Okay, good, a creative collaboration.
I think it needs to be
like a Russian sickle.
(laughs)
You like that one, Jake?
That was the first time I
think I got you for real.
- [Brandon] That's so,
it's, is that random?
- I was born in the Soviet Union,
most Americans don't
know what a sickle is.
Jake's educated, he does,
DRock had no fucking clue.
Okay, what is it DRock?
(muffled, distant reply)
Yeah, okay, good job.
Alright, nonetheless.
Brandon, thank you for being
on the show, man.
- I enjoyed this, yeah.
It's a pleasure, thank you.
- I enjoyed this.
Brandon, ask the question of
the day, any question you want.
You get to ask the
VaynerNation a question.
- What's your favorite moment?
The moment that you'll never forget,
the moment you want
passed down to your kids.
What's the moment that you cherish
and just puts a smile on your face?
- When the Jets beat the Patriots
in the second round of the 2011 play,
I went with Jake's dad, bloopers
in every goddamn episode,
it's still the greatest moment of my life.
- I love hearing people's sports moments,
their favorite moment,
no matter how trite.
- [Gary] You want life or you want sports?
- I like the sports moments--
- Okay so you're clarifying
it, so, wait, it's sports?
- Yeah, I'd love your
favorite sports moment,
whether it's your kid
getting that first hit--
- Yeah, don't talk about
your kid being born,
or like getting into the school,
or getting the job at Gary Vee.
You know, don't do that, make it, make it,
it makes the top 100?
- Yeah.
They don't have everything
bagels in Sweden?
- [Dunc] I don't know what a
fucking everything bagel is.
- Anyway.
- Oh boy, I had Mickey Mantle.
- Brandon, thanks for being a champ.
- You're losing me kid.
- Oh, and by the way, we're
really gonna figure out
if you invented it.
- I appreciate it.
This is hot, thank you.
- You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(energetic bassy music)